Harvey Weinstein was the king of
Hollywood a mogul with 81 Oscars to his
league the Harvey I knew was brilliant I
mean truly brilliant and he ran this
town he was the guy but we'll show you
what actually happened behind his locked
office door the game was about power it
was about making a picture late making
you give in forcing a seduction on you
and speak to those who say they paid an
awful price for being in Weinstein's
world
you ruined lives he crushed dreams I
still am scared of him he is a master
predator now Hollywood's dirty secret is
out in the open we knew everybody knew
everybody now I'm The Reckoning
isn't over it's important for other men
to know you want to act this way then
you're gonna lose everything
mr. Weinstein hi Thomas Peter from Sky
News I wonder if you tell me do you
believe all of those women are lying
do you believe they're lying sir thank
you very much
are you ashamed any messages for the
women Harvey Weinstein has refused all
of our requests for an interview so we
tracked him down on the street he still
wouldn't talk but the women who say he
altered their lives forever will
[Music]
to try and understand what happened we
listen to stories like Rose McGowan who
was one of the first celebrities to
accuse him of sexual assault it was 1997
and she was at the Sundance Film
Festival already a star in the making
Weinstein invited her to his hotel room
where she says he raped her skilled
predators take a lion they look for the
weakest one in the pack don't they the
one without the protection because there
are actresses he didn't target because
they had better representation for
better people around them or there's
something they didn't have that crack
maybe but she targeted an awful lot and
like a super predator you know with
night-vision goggles on he saw what he
needed to see and he did what he needs
to do his whole world was set out to
rape to consume to eat people's lives
he's a dastardly human
I had heard of the casting couch I
thought maybe that was like a rite of
passage and I felt like if this is how
other people make it like it's really
depressing and against everything that I
believe in but when you're in a more
vulnerable position you really don't
have a choice
is what I felt happened that he kind of
made it seem like this was the only way
that he would and it's the only way that
he would ever do it for anyone else I
felt like I said no and he didn't even
acknowledge it I felt like I had to do
it so how is he about it he was calm and
collected this was his like MO he had a
system to bring lure them up ask for the
massage come out in the town robe
he was just active like it was normal
give Weinstein what he wanted or forfeit
a dream
that's the choice dawn Dunning say she
had to make - she's a costume designer
now but back in 2003 she was a young
actress looking for her big break she
met one Steen while she was working in a
nightclub and he said he could help
after several screen tests she went to
what she thought was a business meeting
in a hotel suite when I got there he
opened the door and he was in an open
robe on the coffee table he had three
small stacks of paper and he said these
are contracts for my next three films I
will sign them today but I want you to
have a threesome with me and my
assistant I laughed I thought he was
joking and when I started laughing he
got angry and that's when I got scared
he started yelling at me and
he said you'll never make it in this
business this is how this industry works
this is how he named three actresses how
they got to where they are he went on
and then at that point I the door was
pretty close behind me and I just turned
and went for the door I could still hear
him yelling the more powerful he got the
more blatant the alleged behavior it was
an open secret in Hollywood but even
those who exercised caution say they
were targets like louisette guys who was
invited to pitch a script at the
Sundance festival he said well why don't
we reconvene in my office
well they turn hotel rooms into offices
when you're at these festivals that's
just the norm but I still felt a little
hesitant obviously I knew that this was
a huge opportunity and I didn't want to
give that opportunity up at at the same
time I looked at him in the eye and I
said there's a camera right there so
I'll go up to your office and meet with
you but you're not allowed to touch me
and I said you have to shake my hand
inside the room do we set says things
changed he pulled me to his bathroom and
we both stood in front of the mirror and
he's like just watch me he wanted me to
watch him masturbate and finally I just
ripped my arm away and he followed me
out of the room saying you know look I
can give you a three-picture deal I can
greenlight your film like this is
ridiculous
this is all you have to do everybody
does it you know there's lots of other
women who have done this personally I
think he enjoyed the switch which is
then he comes out he's naked it's a
whole different tone it's the Energy's
different it's much more aggressive and
angry and and he watches us you know
like almost like the prey like okay now
what are you gonna do I think he loved
the power struggle I think he loved to
watch in our faces the fear that's what
I truly believe Weinstein apparently
cast his net wide Lawrence even was a
young reporter when she met him at a
dinner party in a restaurant he
part-owned he offered her a tour of the
kitchen and she followed him I realized
that this was a bad situation and I said
I'm gonna go back upstairs I you know I
saw the kitchen I'm good he leaned in to
kiss me and I said I'm so sorry if I if
I gave you the wrong impression but I'm
not I'm not interested I'm dating
someone you know I'm gonna go back
upstairs and and and at that point he
got kind of irritated and he asked me
just just down there and be quiet and I
I was a little shocked to hear that cuz
his tone changed dramatically but he
blocked my exit and I thought to myself
what is he gonna do and that's when he
just started masturbating in front of me
and I just stood there kind of frozen I
was 27 28 when I had this encounter with
him and I just remember feeling stupid
feeling really dumb standing there and
watching this man
you know do what he was doing and
thinking to myself how could I be so
dumb how could I think that he was
really interested in me and what I had
to say about news and history and world
politics he had a plan he knew exactly
where how to get me down there and just
the the callousness of it like just
stand there and be quiet then because
this is gonna happen whether you
participate or not that was that struck
me as something that he's done before
Sarah Anne mass went to Weinstein's home
to be interviewed for a job as his
children's nanny there she says he
assaulted her I had sort of been warned
by his assistants ahead of time that you
know he was you know he's a Hollywood
guy you know they're kind of different
but never I never translated that to
mean that he was going to you know
sexually assault me during the whole
incident it was just a shock and fear
and discomfort because it you know
you're in a professional environment
it's certainly not something you're
expecting and he also had a huge anger
outburst his children it was just like a
very terrifying experience for me and I
remember really distinctly driving there
I'm the road I took and the exit and
everything and then I don't remember
getting home that constantly felt
trapped he cornered me over over again
every woman we talked to described the
same feeling of being caught in
Weinstein's web entrepreneur Melissa
Thompson says he raped her after a
business meeting
I never had choice like it's Harvey's
choice and it's like Harvey is a playing
cards with a stock deck the outcomes are
fixed the women lose I felt like who
would care that if I said anything
there is still a profound sense of loss
over what might have been
Louie's God bald was a young woman when
she had her own experience with
Weinstein now she's a trauma specialist
a choice shaped by what happened to her
many of us are mourning the careers that
we can pan I think that's the number one
thing that's being warned there are very
many women who are saying that their
careers could have been so much more
illustrious had Harvey not said about
destroying them when you have someone
who is the most powerful man in
Hollywood telling you this is how it
works I believe them you know that you
know was coming from the horse's mouth I
was like okay this is you know not gonna
work for me because I'm not willing I
mean to go that far for it you know when
you're kind of almost hunted and treated
like a piece of meat that does something
to you there's no woman at any stage of
her life should be told that you have to
do a sexual act in order to have a
career I'm sorry but it's pretty basic
Harvey Weinstein has always maintained
that any sexual encounters were
consensual but his accusers say he
preyed on vulnerable young women
unchecked for nearly three decades they
want to know how and why it continued
for so long
there are lots of reasons why no one
stood up to Harvey Weinstein one of them
is that well before he was famous he was
known as a bully in the summer of 1980
Paul or Cho v AK worked for Weinstein on
his first film it was a horror called
the burning
Paula was to become one of the earliest
alleged victims of Weinstein's
inappropriate behavior I didn't realize
how absurd I was until I got outside the
door and I kind of started shaking and I
broke down and started crying later on
set Paula says Weinstein tracked her
down to gloat about exposing himself he
walked up behind me and said so was it
the high point of your internship to see
me naked
I just said no Harvey frankly you
disgust me and he laughed anyone he had
no other reason to be there except to
torment me former employees say it only
got worse from there
Harvey and his brother Bob moved to New
York City to run their film company
Miramax they were cruel both of them
hardly in particular but but bob was
right there with him mark Lipsky was the
head of marketing they couldn't help
themselves every girl in the office
cried I don't know what the expense
budget was for flowers but lots of money
was spent on you know next day apologies
and
begging forgiveness I think a lot of
people who worked for them felt stuck
why don't you think anybody stopped him
it's a big scary guy the people
surrounding both of them but Harvey in
particular were completely dependent on
him and on the company for their careers
and there was scary guys but it wasn't
just about fear Weinstein was a force of
nature and people were drawn to him we
all struggled trying to follow social
norms around him and he unbuttered us
all and he was a very charismatic
confusing powerful frightening exciting
fun too person to be around and you know
he played with all those emotions with
you all the time so you were always in a
sort of state of slight confusion in
survival with him he knew how humans
were that's what made him such a great
storyteller such a great producer the
thing with abusive relationships is that
people keep coming back to them or
rationalizing the behavior that
definitely happened the thing was that
there was such it's almost unfair to
talk about the bad behavior without
talking about the bits of glamour and
the excitement and working with all the
creative people that yet that you were
surrounded with
the circles he ran in words were
extraordinary okay you step into the
room
Madonna says this is John Paul Gautier
and these these guys they're Depeche
Mode there was something sort of very
heady about the atmosphere so it was
like the you would give up some of your
own humility to stick in the job or to
stay in the kind of life Harvey could be
explosive he could be the way he would
verbally attack people and that worked
for him was was vicious it was really
awful I mean he would reduce people to
tears but it always seemed in service of
what he wanted best for a particular
film or a particular project so in a way
in my mind I excused it I said well he's
just that passionate about you know what
he wants for this movie Michael a pasta
Lina was head of creative affairs at
Miramax in the late 80s and early 90s I
guess there was enough that was so
extraordinary and that you were learning
so much and that you know you would work
on something and in the next month it
would be in theaters nationwide and
there would be Oscar talk you know so
the horrible part seemed not okay but I
guess this is the price you know that
you have to pay things moved at
breakneck speed for Bob Weinstein's
assistant Cathy de clases there was
little time to think clearly about what
might have been happening
we were distributing what 1618 films a
year it was insane what was going on
there I remember working probably 80 90
hours a week consistently so you would
see something out of the corner of your
eye when you're running down a hallway
like Harvey flirting with a new blonde
receptionists out of the front and
you're like okay so he's just being a
weasel you know cheating on his wife but
never did I ever think that there was
more than that going on he was just
being kind of lecherous you know in 1990
a serious incident revealed things were
apparently much worse than that but
still Weinstein remained untouchable a
lawsuit was delivered to the office
it was disseminated verbally about what
the contents of this lawsuit were which
was that he had attacked a sexually
attacked or molested an intern and it
all made sense because this this young
woman she worked there for a while she
was very very young very eager and one
day just poof she vanished I opened this
one envelope and from an attorney's
office and this was a very different
kind of a letter all I saw was red
I was completely not only disgusted and
furious everybody started talking about
it and more started coming out another
employee who I can't name pulled me
aside at one point and said boy on this
lawsuit on this one there he's really
gonna have to pay a lot this time
and I was like you know this time so we
knew everybody knew everybody even with
the allegation as common knowledge
nothing happened
to Harvey Weinstein Bob Weinstein says
that he cannot recall the incident and
has always insisted that he didn't know
about the extent of his brother's
alleged harassment and assault of women
do you think that Bob knew what his
brother might have been doing behind
closed doors well he certainly knew when
I handed in the letter that came from
the law office Harvey got a letter Bob
got a letter
Bob knew of course he knew of course you
know how do you not know he was involved
in the settlement for his brother after
an argument Kathy left I said you know
what I quit and your brother is a
[ __ ] pig people might listen to these
stories and say you had a responsibility
I do something I did I did and you
didn't and I did I know that's a
difficult question to answer I I want to
fall back on I was in my early 20s and
it was naivete but that's not really an
excuse
[Music]
it's not that we didn't have a concept
of sexual harassment but we just we
didn't know what to do with it oh this
is terrible but this is what I did
it seemed shrugs awful you know I'm not
going to do anything I swear my children
please even those who didn't shrug it
off were thwarted model
Ambra battle on ado Terez went as far as
wearing a wire for the NYPD after she
reported that Weinstein groped her but
the Manhattan district attorney's office
said the tape wasn't enough to prove a
crime and declined to press charges
others were quietly discouraged from
making a fuss I was told that even if I
said anything that you know he's got a
team of lawyers and
you don't want to do that because
they'll take me down and nobody's gonna
believe you Weinstein's assistant Zelda
Perkins tried to take him on in the
courts after a colleague reported an
attack she spoke up and was silenced he
had done something really heinous and it
was I felt it was partly my
responsibility because I had left this
girl with him to do her job and so it
was my responsibility to make sure that
this was stopped and that this couldn't
happen again and I presumed that the law
would back me up on that instead
Weinstein's legal team swung into action
and like others Zelda found herself
signing a restrictive non-disclosure
agreement it was made very clear to me
right from the start from my own
representation that I was on a losing
ticket and the power disparity was was
too large and who was gonna listen to us
Harvey behaved the way he behaved
because he could he could pay to shut
everything down he had the power to tell
everybody what to do he was above the
law
there have been many reports about what
Harvey Weinstein did but now we can show
you an example of how he behaved behind
closed doors
[Music]
the world watched as Weinstein walked
the red carpets little evidence of his
alleged behavior beyond rumor and gossip
Melissa Thompson changed that by
trusting us to tell her story once she's
kept secret for seven years hoping it
would reveal Weinstein's almost
masterful ability to abuse his power its
September 2011 and 28 year old Melissa
is in the weinstein company offices in
New York City she's here to pitch her
tech startup companies new video
platform and as part of the demo she's
recording the meeting she's expecting to
see the marketing team but Weinstein
arrives alone asked staff for privacy
and locks the door
[Music]
melissa says that a few hours after this
he raped her
I was reading I was thinking okay he's
hugging me what what do I do now I was
sensing I have to be a little bit more
vigilant to this situation than I
originally thought it is so painful to
watch back for multiple reasons because
I look at myself and I had no idea what
was going on Melissa and Weinstein have
met briefly once before but this is
their first formal encounter
[Music]
okay very but that I won't show no what
do you want no it's okay so I've you're
having so many things and we need to say
anything so lots of time every time that
he toed the line of being inappropriate
enough where I may have said something
he could sense it and he pulled me he
pulled back and he changed a dynamic
again let's see I wanted to show Trower
him you know my movie I mean like I mean
I have the Marilyn my boy
so let's have a Marilyn Monroe movie
people who would be interested in that
movie who would be interested okay okay
so would it be what's hard to didn't
grapple with okay so we're gonna buy
space we're gonna buy ad space on Volcom
do you think you might have encouraged
him i don't think i purposely encouraged
him at first I tried to you know volley
a little bit with him you know if you'd
make a comment I would try to catch it
return it in a way that felt its little
safer than the way he threw it at me now
I see he's trying to in any way you can
move me into that zone of comfortable
than uncomfortable and confused and
vulnerable and recognizing that he's
powerful and I'm not and that I need
this deal for him
he's a man he has a power to give it to
me we can have like to win two VIP
passes to the premiere in New York and
they have to like it so now you're
generating all these lights interface
bridge
well
okay yemeni is your service marilyn
realm disciples and so going from almost
pulling a trigger on using this platform
to then you put his hand up under the
table up my chest i was trying to save
face but at first i was trying to kind
of manage a situation there was a
combination of confidence and a naivety
that let me check
you know this dynamic that we see now TV
so hot very crucial to survive it is
[Music]
so another thing I was thinking is surge
I don't know how much you run off at the
surgical park a movie with skyrocket
awesome kind of acting like a by the
look where they wanted to in the trailer
they wanted people to be able to buy her
clothing so they've partnered with
outlook and I tried to keep it on script
in terms of pitching him the product but
I still touched me on the shoulder he
was still touching we have to change our
head as that's happening I what do i do
how did I get myself here I lost my
train of thought and I was trying so
hard to to gain back my own mental
footing at some point he hit his wife
had changed and and he looks at the
predator he is his eyes became dark
I was reeling over the the the dynamic
he created and was controlling and it
couldn't understand how to
counterbalance him and the answers it
was impossible but at the time I didn't
know that and I was sort of struggling
with with it what would you say to
someone who might watch that and say
well - it was flirting with him
is that what you see when you watch it
it was more tricky than I think it's
possible to judge from looking at it
every time Wall Street before I went to
business school and I worked in an
environment that was heavily
male-dominated I thought I could handle
it I had never met any one that I
couldn't handle until Harvey Weinstein
when you go to the kitchen you adjust
the angle of the computer I did why I
knew that I was losing the ability to
control the distribution you keep it
professional so I had injured that
fight-or-flight mode and I was scared of
him you under the impression that that
meeting was to close the deal
potentially yes
so it wasn't at 10:00 p.m. it wasn't an
invitation to come to his hotel room
it was invitation to a hotel lobby that
was within blocks of the office and so
that to me felt much safer than being
alone with him in his office he walked
in with a brisk stride and found me in
the lobby didn't even sit down and I had
ordered a diet coke and he threw cash on
the table I said we're going we're going
this way we get into the elevator and
before I know it he opens the door and
closes it locks it and I look around
eyes --as I'm the hardy wise his hotel
room how how did I get myself here and I
was probably the wrong question to us
how did I get myself here but that's
what I was doing me the entire time
it's difficult to explain but it's
he is a master predator Weinstein denies
all accusations of rape his lawyer at
the time Benjamin Bratt man told us that
there was no evidence of anything
forceful in the video only casual
awkward flirting from both parties he
also said that it was produced by
Melissa to help her case in a civil
lawsuit seeking money for melissa and
many of the other accusers this video
doesn't just reveal bad behavior behind
a locked door it's also evidence of what
they refer to as the Weinstein
complicity machine a system designed to
serve up young women and look the other
way they put money or morals and I want
my daughter to grow up in a world where
decisions are made driven by a sense of
humanity and compassion and people are
held accountable because it's not it's
no longer just it's not just Harvey
Weinstein it's it's many people who
could have still could have done
something and didn't I feel incredibly
angry that Harvey harmed so many women
and that so many people supported his
behavior I think that's been the hardest
thing to recognize is that we were all
duped but duped by groups of people the
only way someone like Harvey Weinstein
gets away with what he did for so long
to so many people is because there are
people facilitating it around him it's
not just people looking the other way
it's people making it happen
I think it was about business they
prioritize business over his behavior
being very immoral unethical it was all
about winning the Oscars and the Oscars
kept coming until something unexpected
brought down the king of Hollywood
[Music]
by 2017 the weinstein company was a
juggernaut worth millions Harvey
Weinstein was part of the network of the
ultra famous uber wealthy and mega
powerful I will be embarrassing many
superstars tonight as usual and I'm
probably in a rare position to be able
to get away with it unfortunately what
can they do about it
but then something extraordinary
happened a small group of women
published their stories that included
Rose McGowan who had finally decided it
was time I've been plotting and planning
and playing my own game of chess because
culturally we weren't there you know we
weren't there and I knew if I had just
come out and some story some little
story I would have been crushed they
were they painted me as if I was erratic
and crazy for years and it would just go
into their PlayBook so I had to wait and
I had to buy my time Zelda Perkins broke
free of her non-disclosure agreement I
realized there must be lots of other
people in my position and that it was
really important to show that if I broke
the agreement the earth wouldn't open up
and swallow me and it would give other
people the courage to come forward and
that we could just get this over and
done with and exposing properly and send
him down they got their timings right
some of the most famous names in
Hollywood came forward alongside dozens
of others
it was one thing that the article came
out and I thought okay well great they
got him yes you will
it was right after that he said oh it's
such a good story I want to buy the
movie rights it was such a condescending
disrespectful comment that I knew I had
to do something and he was threatening
to sue the New York Times and I thought
oh absolutely not
I mean I'll put my face out there I had
no intention of saying anything publicly
because honestly Who am I I'm not you
know a major film star but I knew those
women were telling the truth and I
couldn't believe how brave they were for
coming out against him and so when a
reporter called me and said that he had
heard that something had happened to me
in the past
I said yeah oh I'll tell you everything
I'm telling the truth and I did nothing
wrong and I had to kind of repeat that
to myself to give myself the courage to
just put some it was very private and
very traumatizing out there I didn't
imagine the story to be as big as it was
I really didn't I thought that it would
be out there and he would deny it and
probably pay people to keep quiet about
it and pay to make it go away
I mean that's what he's always done um
but I felt like at least I would feel
like I did my part but the story didn't
go away because all of a sudden all of
these women started coming out of the
woodwork like it was an avalanche of
accusations against him more than he
could keep track of or try and keep
quiet and then I realized Wow
this this is really happening the house
of cards came tumbling down with
astonishing speed Harvey Weinstein's
second wife left him he was sacked from
his own company and he checked into a
rehab clinic for sex addiction
[Music]
but from the ashes of his entertainment
empire rosed the me2 movement and with
it a global reckoning on consent and the
abuse of power
I can't say that I anticipated the
global aspect of it but I was hoping
that it would show people everywhere
that they could topple a power structure
that it would have a big domino effect
for 20 years I have been slut-shamed
I've been harassed would you call what
has been sparked a revolution I think
it's completely revolutionary I can't
remember the last time there was one
other than you know there's a civil
rights movement there's the gay rights
movement we needed a revolution we
needed a reset women have played nice
for a real long time I didn't suspect it
was getting women very far the thing
that puts it in perspective for me is
that so many men they're saying do we
just live in fear you know feel
uncomfortable or question how we're
acting all the time and it's like women
have been doing that all of their lives
and you know welcome to our world
the movement grew some feeling its power
others testing its limits me too
touching every part of society it's got
to stop and it's really mind-blowing
that women are treated this way and and
that we have all been told we have to
just put up with it it's just the way it
is well guess what it ain't that way
anymore
[Music]
in May 2008 een Harvey Weinstein was
arrested and appeared in court charged
with sex crimes seeing him in handcuffs
like made me cry I never thought I would
see the day you know that he would be in
handcuffs like it was amazing
I hope he's convicted I hope this is a
man who who ruined lives I mean he
ruined lives he crushed dreams he really
destroyed so many women I mean he ran
this town he was the guy if you wanted
to be in a film and if you wanted to be
in good award-winning films he was the
only one to go to so I hope he pays for
that
it's important for other men too now you
want to act this way then you're gonna
lose everything and you should lose
everything because you have crushed and
I mean crushed a lot of women the moment
left some of Weinstein's former
colleagues reflecting on the end of an
era they were once so proud of instead
of it being like oh you were at the you
know the top indie shop that changed
changed the film business in the 90s
it's it's now like oh you work for
Harvey Weinstein he sounds like a real
pig
it leaves such a bad taste in your mouth
I just I don't want to relive it
it's truly horrifying what he's done and
[Music]
he deserves everything he gets
[Music]
it's like having somebody retro actively
pull the rug out from under your 20s and
saying it didn't really matter it was
all just awful
you know I when people in my life found
out that I used to work for Miramax they
were impressed and I was proud of that
and now I used to work at a new
york-based home company you know I'm not
gonna say it if I'm not asked because
it's it's it's I'm ashamed of it
I should be shamed the impulse to
worship Weinstein rather than challenge
him may have had consequences on a
jaw-dropping scale dozens of women have
joined forces to sue him and their
lawyer believes there could be many more
how many women do you think Harvey
Weinstein may have targeted I think
we're talking about hundreds I think it
could be near a thousand I I think that
based on what we know and what has
already been made public at least 150
women have come forward in some way on
top of that we have employees who said
that there were women in his office
three times a week where he where they
would have to go in and clean up after
him knowing that he had just done
something and ejaculated so if you're
talking about three times a week at
least for all the number of years that
he's been in power at near Max and The
Weinstein Company there that's a lot of
women and there are questions about how
much really has shifted
do you think there are other Harvey
Weinstein's out there in Hollywood I
know for a fact there are other Harvey
Weinstein's in Hollywood right now I
could name 20 people off the top of my
head right now
it's Hollywood they think if they get
the ugly guy gone and they can return to
their like perfect looking world and
still continue as they continue you know
they think that basically it's like a
red herring for the world look see we
got rid of them they didn't get rid of
they didn't do anything
overtime they gave him new deals and
saved his business over and over many of
the accusers believed that lasting
change will only come if there is
victory in the courts not just against
Weinstein himself but the businesses and
people they believed protected him and
so if we can send the message to these
companies and these people who run these
companies and set a precedent that
protecting predators actually costs me
more money than dealing with them and
doing the right thing then maybe things
will start to change Leeds officer
holding people accountable for
witnessing abuses of power and not
stopping it not saying something not
intervening had people been more vocal
and not said yeah that's Harvey or yeah
I we have to look at that you don't we
don't have to live with things that are
illegal and abusive and and we don't
have to we don't have to live with being
raped only think we're going to a
business meeting
the environment has to be changed you
know the system that enables the
behavior you know this is much bigger
than Harvey Weinstein and it's much
bigger than gender it's about power and
it's about how we respond as a culture
to power there has been story after
story but Harvey Weinstein has
consistently denied all allegations of
non-consensual sexual contact his
brother Bob and other executives named
in lawsuits also deny any wrongdoing the
Weinstein story and the fallout continue
[Music]
you